we're here with brad and rachel a
happily married couple
and we're talking to them about having
different parenting styles for their
three children and i'm here with my good
friend
and parenting expert and child
behavioralist
dr elisa pressman so when we went out of
commercial breaks
one of the things that we were talking
about was that you guys have different
styles
and one of the things i found is such a
pitfall
is that we have to have a united front
and what's so difficult about that is
you are
two individuals who are expected to
become one person
one mentality and i find that
the difficult thing about that is if you
try to conform
to someone else eventually you will lose
yourself
and i believe it is human behavior that
we will inevitably
fight to become ourselves again which
usually means we're going to have to
distance from the other person
so if you guys want to stay connected is
there ever going to be a day where you
guys can get to a place where you
celebrate each other's different styles
i think that's a really great way to
look at it um i don't think before
we you know have been speaking with you
that that was something
that we felt like was even an option
looking at it from that perspective and
him being one style and me being another
and that being okay
i think is probably the only way to move
forward without
eventually going separate ways yeah i
think that's a great point
lisa what do you think what a great
place to come to to honor the fact that
you each come from different places
and there's a benefit to knowing that
mom is a particular way and dad is a
particular way kids are very smart and
they'll just kind of learn who to go to
for certain things and that's totally
okay
you know it's funny because sometimes
aliza we did like a design thing
together recently
and she was talking about how kids like
have a literally a different
eye perspective you know i don't who
knows if your kids see
you know you rachel as the bad cop and
you know they may look at their dad and
see this very bigger than life figure
and be slightly intimidated and you
might be
this cozy safe person and elisa is right
if you lay down the law and you are full
of boundaries
it does not drive your children away
they do actually feel a sense of safety
from those boundaries which i was
terrified of for years and it turns out
it's true
yeah that's really something for me to
grab a hold to
and take comfort in rachel what is like
ideally your favorite healthy snack oh
gosh
um i like to hit all the major food
groups how long do you have i know
let's go back to like a basics nutrition
course um
i like to do a protein a carbon fat and
so
ideally a whole food from each of those
categories okay
and brad what are you giving the kids
fruit snacks nutter butters every once
in a while
you know things that we have on hand
usually yeah that doesn't sound
so bad look i'm like both of you i've
got to be
i'm a single mom you know i understand
i'm two people in one
so i think that you're both right and i
think
we both try to do you know by the way i
just talked about myself we both
okay do you see what i'm saying um the
two of me
hot why how dare you i'm doing good no
you're not
that's uh you know there's that style of
parenting too
so look i get it we're all just trying
to do the best we can
and if we try to find that pretty little
middle
within ourselves yes what no then
you know i think life will be a little
bit easier
you guys really have an energy
about you that's loving and i think if
kids also
see conflict or differences or different
styles but they know you can figure out
how to resolve it
they're going to figure out that they
can go through life which is never
you know without its conflicts and know
that they can resolve things too
elisa yes yes
it's not that we want to hide conflict
from kids it's just that we want to
finish the story
like we've got this guys we're not we're
not in agreement here but this is how we
resolve it
because then you'd get to your 20s and
you'd fight with someone and think i
guess this is it then
i've never seen a fight before i know
you know oh please my parents split
before i was born and i was like
every time someone would say goodbye i'd
be like where are you going to the
grocery store
you have to make a big deal out of this
goodbye it could be the last time
that's not supposed to be sad i'm great
actually everything that happened in my
life has led me to be
a really strong person and i think that
these are some of the most
interesting exciting fun
and important conversations to have in
life because we are all trying to
navigate relationships
and when it comes to our kids it's just
such high stakes
so the stress is totally natural drew
we want to give you the honorary title
of doctor i mean you're
you're doing really great this is
awesome really
yeah yeah you have lots of great sports
oh my god thank you well i'm
here's my truth is that
i have learned from such smart people
like this woman who's sitting right here
but really i thank you guys for trusting
us enough to come
and tell your story and share your
experiences with
us and you guys seem to really love each
other and it's nice
to have that hope you know because
couples fighting it it's so tense and
scary for all of us
and so when you see someone who you guys
do really like each other you do really
love each other
and we're gonna figure this out it was
an honor it was an honor to be here with
you and honestly
seriously being completely honest i
think this conversation probably is
changing the trajectory of
how like things have been so heavy
lately and
part of it is our kids ages and we're in
the thick of it for sure but
like if we can't figure out how to
co-exist as parents then
i don't know and i think you know having
like this outside view
of our you know parenting style and our
relationship
looking in and like you know you guys
telling
us how it looks saying we're both right
and saying that you can tell we love
each other is
i don't know we needed this this was
awesome i'm so glad
and alisa can you also tell them the
thing about the dinner table
because i we all try to do that same
thing like i
it's like oh hi cue the norman rockwell
painting aren't we pretty
what yeah you get like 10 minutes with
from a two-year-old
definitely set the tone we're gonna have
the our nice dinner conversations but
for 10 minutes
and then every time they have a birthday
add a little bit of time but
you're not gonna get a long it's
it's never gonna happen so you're just
gonna have tension and you want meal
time to be fun
um i just really wanna thank you guys
again and thank you aliza
i love you thank you i love you thank
you to everybody watching
[Music]
you